des organismes appelle le gouvernement
fédéral à freiner d'urgence leva potage
une coalition qui comprend notamment
l'association médicale canadienne et la
société canadienne du cancer réclame
l'interdiction du marketing des produits
de vapo taz qu'on limite aussi les
arômes disponibles et qu'on réglemente
la teneur en nicotine
cet appel survient alors qu'un premier
cas de maladie grave lié au pape otages
a été signalés en ontario
aux etats unis les états et les
autorités ont répertorié 530 cas de
maladies pulmonaires et cette mortalité
avec nous patrick phare professeur
agrégé à l'école supérieure d'affaires
publiques et internationales à
l'université d'ottawa bonsoir monsieur
faveur bonsoir
quand on parle de cigarettes
électroniques de vin potage quelle est
la part de marché des cigarettes
électroniques
la cigarette électronique du marchix
totale du tabac est environ de 6 7%
dépendant du mois ouais mais laissez
donc les cigarettes domine toujours
on a préparé un graphique qu'on va voir
à l'écran là les cigarettes domine
toujours aux états unis chez nous aussi
effectivement la très grande majorité
des consommateurs du nicotine utilisent
les cigarettes combustible du city raid
traditionnelles
ouais est ce que le 81 % de gens qui
utilisent la cigarette ce sont tous des
clients potentiels pour le vha potage
effectivement et c'est ça l'enjeu
essentiel la cigarette combustible est
très dangereux plats santé et leva
potage est une alternative qui est
nettement mieux pour ceux qui consomment
des jeux du tabac par deux cigarettes
traditionnelles
est-ce qu'il est clair pour vous et est
ce qu'on comprend de ce qu'on s'est
jusqu'à maintenant que le vha potage la
cigarette électronique
c'est un produit qui est dangereux c'est
un produit c'est un produit qui n'a pas
d'effet pour ceux qui n'ont jamais
consommé le tabac qui le fut en ce
moment on ne fait pas ce sera une très
mauvaise idée de commencer leva partage
mais pour ceux qui sont déjà des fumeurs
souvent pendant de longues années
c'est une alternative très intéressant
donc c'est préférable de vapoter que
deux fûts
mais effectivement cigarettes et le
statistiques utilisées au royaume uni
c'est que le silure et électroniques et
de 95 % moins nocif que le cigarette
combustible ouais mais là il ya des
inquiétudes aujourd'hui de très
sérieuses inquiétudes vous vous dites
que le bape otages c'est le hub air des
cigarettes dites nous pourquoi vous
dites ça mais c'est que on fait face à
un changement technologique très
importante dans l'industrie du tabac
de la même façon que hubert lancer la
balle à l'industrie du taxi la cigarette
électronique introduit un élément
technologique
une alternative est ça le risque de
révolutionner l'industrie du tabac est
ce qu'il est démontré que le vha potage
à un effet réel pour faire cesser de
fumer
les études on le produit n'existe que
depuis quelques années alors les études
sont ne sont pas encore conclusif mais
un chiffre très important au même moment
que la consommation du tabac et le
cigarette traditionnelle est à la baisse
la consommation due car l électronique
et d'al haouz alors on a des raisons de
croire que les consommateurs en place
l'un avec l'autre et on a des onsen on a
des indications que c'est beaucoup plus
facile d'arrêter la consommation avec
les cigarettes électroniques parce qu'on
peut davantage contrôler le montant de
nicotine qu'on a dans notre dans notre
système est ce qu on comprend clairement
que les cas qui sont rapportés cet
adolescent qui a une maladie pulmonaire
ou les 500 personnes aux états unis les
mâts mortalité sont véritablement prouvé
comme étant le ligue 1 reportage ils
sont liés au vha potage mais ce qui
n'est pas loin des clercs est ce que ces
gens là ont consommé des produits
légales ont produit des produits des
produits à base de tabac ou est ce qu on
consommer des produits illégale non
réglementée basé sur le cannabis il ya
de fortes indications que celle
le problème laquelle on fait face en ce
moment c'est des produits ceux qui
viennent du marché noir
ah oui et la mise en garde de santé
canada qu'est ce qu'on doit comprendre
aujourd'hui de cela en comparaison avec
d'autres gouvernements ailleurs au monde
l'annoncé d'aujourd'hui de santé quand
elle est assez bien équilibré on indique
clairement comprend des gestes pour
ainsi de bien comprendre les maladies
qui ont aidé à laquelle fait face en ce
moment mais on éclaire à dire que les
gens qui fument des jeunes filles est on
peut peut-être pas dans notre intérêt de
la rai tilda potage l'inde interdit le
potage la n va beaucoup plus loin
effectivement ce qui est assez
intéressant avec ce produit là
différents pays ont des réactions
complètement différente
alors d'un côté de l'inde et d'autres
pays d'asie qui le voit comme étant le
risque d'empoisonnement il interdit
complètement
à l'autre extrême la rue mini qui trouve
que c'est un produit fort intéressant et
on le support de l'état britannique est
en angleterre c'est un produit qui vu
comme étant tout à fait normal
- est-ce qu'on doit aller plus loin dans
notre encadrement est ici effectivement
c'est un nouveau produit il ya beaucoup
changé dans très peu de temps
alors certains des on devrait par
exemple imaginer à réglementer le
montant de nicotine dans chaque
cigarette électronique ce qu'on n'a pas
encore fait d'autres disent qu'on
devrait arrêter de permettre la vente de
saveur ce qui risque de peut-être
limiter le nombre de jeunes qui commence
bien mais les faits or ils n'ont pas
souhaité que les fumeurs qui fument déjà
on sort moins intéressés à passer du
sacré combustible aux cigarettes
électroniques et est ce que si on freine
leva potage on pourrait assister à une
remontée des fumeurs de cigarettes
effectivement chaque personne qui fume
déjà le siret électronique cioran soit
plus difficile plus compliqué et cette
personne ne retourne au cigare être
compétitive mais là les effets de ces
sur la santé vont sont réels dernier
point les cigarettiers s'infiltre dans
l'industrie du verre potage on parle
d'elle d'altria par exemple qui devient
actionnaire de deux jours c'est le plus
gros vendeur de cigarettes
électronique aux états unis donc les
cigarettiers voit qu'une façon de
transiter vers un autre marché
différentes compagnies ajustent de
différentes façons effectivement altria
s'est donné une position dans le marché
aux états unis
ici au canada il ya produit dans
certaines provinces views qui est un
produit d'une pure de baco mais d'autres
combien tabac veulent pour le moment du
moins semble vouloir ne pas aller dans
cette direction là alors ça fait un
effet pervers parce que dans cent sûr
tant qu'on limite l'accès aux cigarettes
électroniques c'est la table avantages
de ces compagnies là qui contient à
mettre l'emphase sur la cigarette
traditionnelle
merci monsieur phare pour ses
explications ce soir bienvenue